anaëlle leclerc 14 ans espoir du tennis
français
lac et l'atelier donc
forcés
j'ai commencé quand j'avais 6 ans à
tremblay en france c'était du baby
tennis c'est pas vraiment tennis fin
c'est pour apprendre puis après j'ai
déménagé dans le centre à
saint-amand-montrond et j'ai commencé à
jouer vraiment tennis
qu'ai je fait une année en fait au jus
appris le tennis et on va la pousser de
vue que je pouvais de la compétition
j'ai commencé j'ai été championne
départementale après j'ai pas un
original et puis après un peu plus tard
dans l'année dernière le stan et jeter
championne de france en double et j'ai
quand même été sélectionné en équipe de
france c'était bien derrière tout tout
tout est statique chez toi en dépit de
son jeune âge un palmarès éloquent et
une petite expérience sur le circuit
international doit voir que tout se met
en place
quand et comme ça c'est super et j'ai
fait pas mal de pays en europe
j'ai déjà fait les stagiaires ont tourné
j'ai pas encore fait puisque asie voilà
ayant tu retires oui j'ai pas mal voyagé
un talent indéniable de nombreuses
heures d'entraînement avec des jeunes de
sa catégorie d'âge et des adultes
ils sont quatre à venir régulièrement
temps en temps si tu mets change un peu
la trajectoire sortante pour la faire
changer de vitesse de jambes c'est bien
ça c'est intéressant comme travail pour
nous c'est indispensable c'est vraiment
un dispositif qui permet d'avoir une
qualité de balle qui permet d'avoir une
intensité et qui permet d'avoir
finalement une qualité d'entraînement
nettement plus aisée des entraînements
en petit comité la fédération à déléguer
aux ligues la prise en charge des jeunes
talents sa structure accueille des
jeunes qui sont sur des projets forts
internationaux qui ont besoin de temps
pour s'entraîner tant besoin une
scolarité un petit peu différente c'est
à dire une scolarité plutôt par
correspondance avec un couteau rings
online and hell est un troisième cours
d'histoire entre deux séances tennis le
planning est très serré
ah c'est bien en question non non ça va